I have the funniest thing to show you
Donald Trump is of course panicking
about his former national security
adviser John Bolton possibly testifying
in the Senate impeachment trial now why
is Donald Trump panicking John Bolton
says in his upcoming book and would
likely say under oath that he knows
Trump with was withholding aid from
Ukraine until they smear Joe Biden
because Trump personally told him that
this is the assertion that John Bolton
has made so yesterday Donald Trump
retweeted a video of John Bolton being
interviewed by Radio Free Europe back in
August with the text game over in all
capital letters of letters so clearly
Donald Trump believes that what Bolton
says in this video proves either that
Bolton is lying about what Trump told
him regarding withholding aid to Ukraine
or that what Bolton says proves Trump
really did care about corruption in
Ukraine and not smearing Joe Biden or
whatever the case may be so I was
interested and I watched the clip which
is only 40 seconds long and what Bolton
says is definitely not exculpatory of
Donald Trump and it actually could be
self incriminating if we pay close
attention to what it is that John Bolton
says so let's first take a look at the
clip then I'll explain to you what is
going on here I will be meeting
President zalenski he and President
Trump have already spoken twice
President called to congratulate
President Solinsky on his election and
then on his success in the parliamentary
election they were very warm and cordial
calls we're hoping that they'll be able
to meet in Warsaw and have a few minutes
together because the success of Ukraine
maintaining its freedom its system of
representative government a free market
economy free of corruption and dealing
with the problems of the Donbass and the
Crimea are high priorities here
obviously but high priorities for the
United States as well so what's the big
deal well John Bolton says in this clip
the success of Ukraine maintaining its
free-market economy free of corruption
is a high priority in the United States
you don't usually say we want to
maintain something unless it already
exists john bolton says in this clip
that the Trump administration wants to
maintain Ukraine corruption free now
Donald Trump and his lawyers have been
arguing endlessly that Donald Trump did
all of this crazy stuff because Ukraine
is so corrupt and the corruption has to
be fixed and Trump feels so strongly
about it that he said let's pause the
aid that's the word they've now been
using and yet john bolton said back in
august we want to maintain ukraine's
free market corruption free economy this
makes it more likely that fixing
ukrainian corruption was never really
the issue because john bolton said in
august they are corruption free and a
free-market economy so this is a new
data point and this new data point
suggests that at least john bolton
didn't see Ukraine as a corruption
riddled mess since he says we want to
keep Ukraine free of corruption
now you can parse the language some
other way you could rewrite the
interpretation you could say well it
used to be not corrupt and then at the
time of this interview Ukraine went back
to being corrupt and what Bolton meant
is they want to go in and rid Ukraine of
corruption that's fine right and we
there's no question that to some degree
Ukraine does deal with corruption that's
not what's at issue here but the plain
and simple Occam's razor interpretation
is that Bolton is saying in the clip
which is about six months old
Ukraine is relatively corruption free
and we want to keep it that way this
hurts the credibility of Donald Trump
story because we are told that Trump was
so acutely concerned with corruption in
Ukraine which was the acutely corrupt
place that he went out of his way and
personally got involved in saying let's
withhold the aid temporarily let's pause
it as they say until corruption is
routed out in Ukraine it's just not
believable when you see john bolton say
yeah we want to keep ukraine corruption
free number two there's a reason Donald
Trump tweeted this
Donald Trump tweeted this video because
he thinks it makes him look good
Trump is tweeting John Bolton's own
words as reliable evidence in other
words Trump tweets this video because he
believes that the content of what John
Bolton is saying is excope Ettore we've
already showed that the content of what
Bolton says is not exculpatory but the
fact that Trump is saying watch this
video to figure out why I'm not guilty
means he thinks Bolton can be believed
in other words if he believed Bolton was
a liar he wouldn't tweet a clip saying
look at what Bolton says is evidence
that I didn't do anything wrong
so Trump wants you to believe that he's
innocent because you can trust what
Bolton says in the clip I just played
for you but he also wants you to believe
that if Bolton were to testify in the
impeachment trial and show up and say
Trump told me to withhold the aid until
Ukraine smears Biden in that case you
would not be able to believe John Bolton
in this case John Bolton's words are so
trustworthy that as far as Donald Trump
sees that they are exculpatory it's a
mess it is an incoherent laughable mess
and in the end it's probably not gonna
matter I wish I had some other
conclusion that was less disgusting but
in the end it probably won't matter
because I continue to believe acquittal
is a foregone conclusion and I know
every time I say this someone writes to
me sometimes people will say David
you're being defeatist
no I'm being realistic someone will
write to me let's say David by
predicting the acquittal of Trump you
were normalizing disgusting partisanship
on the baja on the behalf of republicans
no I'm not normalizing it I'm telling
you it's so bad that there's not even
really a trial going on here it's just a
farce it's a kangaroo court they may not
even have witnesses if you can imagine
that so I am a realist on this program I
don't know what the audience gains from
me saying hey guys I really think
there's a shot if we call our senators I
don't that's my belief and if I end up
being proven wrong I will come back here
and say I got it wrong but I'm not gonna
gasp like the audience and if the real a
if the reality of what I tell you
makes you feel bad or makes you feel
like we're can see
I am informing you to the best of my
ability I don't see any path to
conviction for Donald Trump in the
Senate impeachment trial and so I'm not
gonna pretend otherwise I see a possible
path to getting witnesses if a few
Republicans say let's get witnesses here
I see a path to that I see no path to
Donald Trump's conviction I see one path
to his removal and it's an overwhelming
turnout against Trump in the November
election coming up in just nine months
follow the David Pakman show on
Instagram for more on this and other
stories from today at David Pakman show
and follow me on Instagram why not right
at David Pakman we'll take a quick break
so much more to discuss today if you
enjoy shows like Shark Tank or you're
fascinated by entrepreneurs and how they
become successful I've got something
really cool for you to check out it's a
YouTube channel we're partnering with
called up flip and you can find it at
david pakman.com slash up flip it's a
new channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in up flips videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business
every entrepreneur on up flip has their
own story to tell they're all
fascinating check it out if you watch my
show check out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really a
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip